you
you
hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast significantly simplify your
plant metabolomics workflow I am joined
akeli chem lab roots now I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab rats and
sponsored by phi x phi x helps to
improve the world we live in by enabling
scientists and laboratory analysis to
find answers to the complex analytical
challenges they face for more
information please visit www SI XCOM
before we begin we have a few
announcements this webcast is designed
to be interactive so live hear from you
you can submit questions or comments by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window answer is always
welcome to will try to answer as many
questions as we can you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you have any
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problems to the Green two and a button
lower left if you look at your screen
now you should see two polling questions
coming up the first is how are you
currently analyzing metabolomic sample
and the second is what improvements
would you like to see when analyzing
metabolomic samples if you could take a
minute to answer those questions we
would really appreciate it I would now
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Stephen Locke dr. Stephen Locke obtained
his PhD in physical organic chemistry
from the University College of Swansea
in 1993 and is a chartered chemist and a
member of the royal society of chemistry
previously a lecture of chemistry at the
University of Hull and a senior
scientist at CCF RA he has worked for
psychics in various technical roles for
over 16 years he has over 25 years
experience in analytical chemistry and
has presented at over 50 international
meetings around the world steve is
currently business development manager
for the separation division of socks
covering Europe the Middle East Africa
and India I will now turn it over to dr.
Locke for his presentation
thanks Brenda for the kind introduction
and thank you everyone for attending
today today's presentation is going to
be on the use of CES IMS in the analysis
of metabolomics samples I'm just going
to move to the next slide so the talk
outline basically what I'll start with
is going through what C esi-ms is and
then we're going to look at examples
where we can apply this into
metabolomics can I focus on two main
areas the first one is the application
of C esi-ms in cationic metabolomics and
the next one is the application of CSI
ms into an ionic metabolomics I
negatively charged species so what is
CSI MS well actually it's the connection
of kapil electrophoresis to mass
spectroscopy via the lacs spray
interface so it's basically the seamless
connection of Cee with mass spec we do
this by physically connecting the
capillary coming straight out of the sea
instrument to a nano spray source
connected to a mass spectrometer in this
diagram here what you see is the the
instrument which is the sea instrument
CSI 8000 and then GN arrow which
connects it to a crippled top instrument
triple toddlers and accurate mass cute
off instrument from sykes and it stands
for the integration of khopoli actor
paresis with electrospray ionization
into a single dynamic process within the
same device so basically it really is
the simple plug-and-play connection of
Cee to mass spec without the addition of
any other modifiers or gases just the
plug in connection of ze to mass spec
and one of the benefits of doing this is
that you can actually then run the c/e
at its flow rate directly into the mass
spectrometer now this has huge benefits
in the area of iron generation and for
those people of use mass spectroscopy
over the years everyone knows that
there's an increase in sensitivity when
you decrease the flow rate of your
analyte into the mass spectrometer and
this slideshare shows the the general
decrease in flow rate with a technique
so you can see going from high flow way
you use two point one to four point six
millimeter columns here the flow rates
are in the region of 200 michael it's
from in it up to a couple of miles a
minute and then you go right down and
flow rates down to nano LC which is in
the order of a couple of hundred nana
liters per minute and then to CSI ms
here you're running at lone nana liters
per minute so it actually connects the
sea directly to the mass spec and these
ultra low flow rates then go straight
into the mass spectrometer violin and a
spray source this happens in the opti ms
kapil array so this is the connection to
the mass spec from the c/e instrument
and this is where all this is where it
really happens that the science behind
the connection so in this connection
what we have is the capillary running
from the cee and this is the same
capillary you load your sample into and
apply the separation voltage it run
through this octi ms cartridge and then
it goes through an area work which
contains conductive liquid so it's like
electrospray ionization where you have a
hollow tube into which a another
capillary runs in when you do any
standard electrospray ionization you
have a gas around that you generate the
spray here we apply a liquid the liquid
is conductive liquid and that transfers
the iron spray voltage to the capillary
to generate the spray are these low flow
rate you don't need gas you don't need
make-up liquid all you need is the
application of a voltage
to generate the spray for lactose prey
and this is actly how we do it so and
this means we can run the cee flow act
without mixing directly into the mass
spec and the capillary length used is
standing these cartridges about 90 91
centimeters and we use a narrow internal
diameter 30 micro meter diameter and
this is all patented technology owned by
owned by psychics and then based on a
pay for an ounce of chemistry in 2007
the reason it works so well is that
these ultralow these of slow flow rates
is this less competition for charge for
you compound so you your effective iron
generation is dramatically increased and
also what she had what you have left to
compete with it it's the loss of solvent
because you have less solvent flown into
the instrument all this give you huge
benefits and iron generation and and it
means that you can even with the low
volumes that you inject onto these nano
capillaries and cee you still get very
good sensitivity an excellent peak shape
of the CD and this sensitivity is shown
in this next slide this is a bar graph
shown the change in iron generation when
you decrease the flow rates so you can
see from the the right hand side here
which is at 359 liters per minute you
refine generation at infusion is around
about a couple e to the seven however
when you start decreasing the flow rate
down towards the left hand side of this
graph down to where the sea esi-ms runs
at you see a massive increase in iron
generation and this is really increase
the sensitivity of this approach and
it's a bit and is hugely different to
the traditional way of connected CTMS
which required she flow and she's gas
which effectively diluted out your
sample and decreased the sensitivity
that's in it in this case there's no
dilution sample you run the flow
directly into the mass spec this is all
connected via this via an optimist
capillary which which fits directly into
a hold in an anise
a sauce so here we see the
implementation of the CSI ms technique
when you combine it with a [ __ ] tov
instrument so here you can find the the
ultra resolution Cee with a high
resolution of ms detection and the
system and the system is also capable of
course of using standard CD detection
techniques as well so you can in a way
to the detection techniques do you use
your you see in UV detection mode to do
the method development and then change
it to the CSI modes connect the
capillary to the mass spec and then do
ms detection now this is already been
applied in proteomics and omics research
area and this slideshare shows you a
screen capture of some results on an
omics research paper and this was done
by professor Herbert Linda of the
University of Innsbruck in Austria and
Maurice done here is just compared none
o LC with CSI MS in in section of
peptides and proteins in a select sample
which has taken from a yeast and digest
and here you can see the complementarity
nature of CSI compared to LC now CSI ms
of course separates the components of a
mixture based on its charge in science
where's LC separates it based on
typically on interactions with the
stationary phase and so that the total
different ways of separating analytes
and here you can see the benefits of
this approach when you compare in the
two techniques in this case it's just
just to show you how CSI and LC a
complementary nature in this these sort
of Venn diagram you see what you're
seeing is the oval opportunity
techniques in the middle and then you're
seeing the the enhancement or the
detection of additional peptides and
read by CSI MS and you only detection of
other peptides not picked up by CSI ms
in blue which were picked up by nano LC
but it does show the complementary
nature of these two techniques
what we can see in the future 40 mix
research metabolomic sam proteomics is
probably people doing both techniques to
get full characterization of songs so
how does this apply to metabolomics well
because siiii is a technique which is
based on charge and size separation
really where this of this technique
applies to metabolomics is in the area
of polar metabolomic so this is the
polar metabolites and these are actually
a difficult area for LC LC to analyze
because often have retention issues on
standard reverse phase stationary phases
and this also have matrix interferences
as well one of the benefits which I
haven't shown here CSI ms is that when
you're running up these real low flow
rates it also helps with reducing matrix
of pressure because it's less
competition for charge of these lower
flow rates so it also helps a Maitre
suppression so this is an additional
benefit of this technique I was
especially in polar metabolomics which
have issues with matrix suppression
because they often lose at the front of
reverse phase separations and it's been
some research research papers already in
this area and using seeking combination
of mass spec and there's been some
research paper by the silver group in
Japan and also by the group in in leiden
university medical center and in Leiden
University where they've already tried
to combine papillae actually
electrophoresis with mass spec in the
area of catalonia metabolomics so this
this history behind the use of this
approach already in metabolomics but at
the end of last year beginning of this
year i was posed by a researcher in
europe who is interested in perla
metabolomics and whether the new CSI ms
can be used in this technique and what
he asked with some probing questions the
first one was can you analyze and
derivatives amino acids as well as an
ionic metabolites in
capillary because ideally what he wanted
was a technique where he didn't have to
change in the hardware you could just
flip between methods and run the room
cationic metabolites to look for catto
metabolites in one method and then flip
and inject again and look for an ionic
metabolites in are using the same
capillary and ideally the same back row
extra light solution the other question
he asks can you detect these metabolites
the physiological relevant levels and
this is specifically in the area of
plant metabolomics and can you also
separates isobaric metabolites which
were often just geometric isomers by CSI
MS and here he had some specific
questions around phosphorylated sugars
because he has he has encountered issues
of separation when he's trying to do
this by hillock chromatography and also
by ion chromatography in connection to
mass spectrometry and finally can you do
all this with low sample consumption and
really is this around the ability to to
run CSI ms initial in your sample and
then use the same sample to apply it to
another technique for example lcms and
also in some metabolomic studies for
example a mouse analysis sample volume
is limited so this is a specific need
for that particular application area the
first the first question the first area
I looked at was the application of CES
IMS in the area of detecting cationic
metabolites are using positive
electrospray ionization and this is the
area really of detecting in this case
under riveters amino acids as well as
other metabolites which are positively
charged in electrospray and actually
what I did was took a method that we use
for triptych digesting and simply apply
this to this area of of analysis so in
this case how you set up the ce4
separation is the first you have to
condition the capillary
I did this by using water methanol
rinses and then you load your capillary
with a background electrolyte solution
in this case we used ten percent acetic
acid you feel a conductive line so you
enable this circuit to transfer the ice
baby otters to the spray and then you
load your sample I didn't use electro
kinetic injection I simply used pressure
fill of the syringe of a certain period
of time and then you apply your
separation voltage to separate your
metabolites in this case why I also did
was I made at my samples in a hundred
millimole ammonium acetate so I could do
some on column stacking you've like with
it using a technique odd-eyes attack for
esa's and this basically allowed me to
inject more material onto the capillary
to get a higher loading volume for the
MS method I sort of used the cute off
instrument in effectively you like a
triple quadrupole system what I actually
did was dedicated dedicated product iron
scans acura mass product iron scans for
the amino acids I wanted to detect and I
also added of course a screening and
time-of-flight single-stage mass spec
scan to pick up other metabolites and
samples in this case the turtle scan
time was of the order 1.2 seconds minus
is due to the fast scanning speed of the
5600 triple tov instrument which is
capable of doing 50 plus selling 50
product on scans per second so it can
operate similar to speeds of a triple
quadruple or cue track system regardless
testing of the source of course you
don't need gas to generate the spray you
don't need make-up solution so the only
setting you do to generate the spray and
is applying an iron spray voltage and
then you just position is grade to get
the best sensitivity for your mouth
and here you see some of the data and
this was based on the standard provided
me by the customer and these are the
sort of the levels you expect to see in
his plant extracts and here you see a
series of amino acids all under
advertised and these are separated in
the order of I think it's about 20
minutes with the runtime here for
separation of n derivatives amino acids
by CSI MS and this has also been run on
a triple quadrupole system and for this
particular application we have an
application as already available for
people are interested in in and riveters
amino acids and you can also see gather
at the bottom as well so the method
itself included other positively charged
metabolites as well as mainly under the
ties amino acids in this case and so
that seems to work quite well and this
is what I expected to be honest for
positively charged compounds but I
suppose the major challenge for me was
actually flipping this now to connect
see sims2 negatively negative
electrospray because if you look at the
literature that I have there are some
questions around that the possibility to
do in this and what I try to do
initially was to use the same
methodology as they use for the cationic
screen same capillary the same
background electrolyte solution and to
start to run in negative electrospray of
course now you're looking at negatively
charged ions to the thing you have to do
here in the method is change the plow to
the separation voltage to drive your
target compound to the mass spectrometer
so the one thing you do change in the
method between the cationic and anionic
screen is you change the polarity or the
separation voltam you go to reverse
polarity rather than normal and of
course the other thing you need to do is
change the polarity of your interview
mass spectrometer and detecting negative
Alex prey rather than positive
electrospray and this gives you a
breakdown of the method I used to
I say samples for the negative
metabolites and here you can see the
separation voltage is very similar to
the positive method I used I used a
pressure injection and in this case it
was a 30-second 5 psi injection of a
sample which is equivalent to ten to
twenty nine liters of sample on column
the same capillary was used to both
methods I've actually used a bear
Lucilla caterpillar II and the same
background electrolyte was used so
surprisingly enough I never changed the
background electrolyte solution so in
this case I used 10 verse in acetic acid
as a background electrolytes and acetic
acids prefer because it it's better for
negative electrospray for iron
generation and then finally the other
change the method really is the movement
of the polarity of the separation
voltage from normal to reverse phase for
the MS the main thing here is the is the
change of polarity of detection and
electrospray electrospray so you're
moving from now to negative mode I had a
very similar setup so i did dedicated
product iron scans for a series of
negative metabolites and a single stage
tov scan for detected none no
metabolites again i tried to keep the
cycle time low because of the sharp
peaks you get but in the cee separation
for the high resolution separation so
again the cycle time even with 50
product iron scans anatov ms gang was
less than 1.5 seconds miserable self
again all I have to set was the ein
spray voltage in the source to generate
spray and the position of the source of
the same for both methods the first
thing I try to do is separate to
disaccharides which were phosphorylated
these are isobaric which means they have
the same molecular weight in the same
empirical formula so you ideal to
separate these because also some of the
major fragment times the same what you
tend to see in phosphorylated comp
is that one of the major metabolites so
we're major fragment times in ms ms
analysis is the phosphate group so will
be the same for both of these compounds
and but what you can see shear is that
using this acetic acid as a background
electrolytes and using reverse phase
polarity we managed to actually separate
these two isobaric phosphorylated
disaccharides the one thing I did here
was I tried to increase the speed of
sample analysis so I actually increase
the pressure on the separation so one
thing you can do to speed up analysis is
apply pressure to the separation as well
and I move from point 5 psi 2 psi
pressure applied to the capillary Joe
and the separation of metabolites and
here you can see it's speeded up and
spits bed visit the separation by
approximately two minutes so that's one
way you can increase the throughput of
you an asus in this case and the south
was simply diluted into water so i
haven't tried to ice attacker for recess
here this is just straight forward
pressure injection of the of a sample
and before separation and one of the key
things should of course when you do this
sort of work is to check on linearity i
did this by repeat analysis of standards
to check to make sure it's linear and
the linear range for the r-squared
number i got for this separation and for
both of these two phosphides
disaccharides which are important
implant metabolomics is the order of
point nine nine so it was a linear
response i never used any internal
standards that's all in this this
approach and this is probably one of the
most important slides our show today one
of the biggest hurt that I suppose needs
of this particular area is not the
disaccharides but this is the separation
of of mono phosphorylated sugars which
are important in in the glucose cycle
another to the energy cycle of
of clients as well as of animals and
here you can see example where I've
separated three phosphorylated sugars
this is extremely difficult to do you
can't do this by reversed-phase
chromatography and people struggle to do
this by hillock and other means to get
the resolution you see in this diagram
so what you see here is a separation of
glucose 1-phosphate from fructose will
phosphate from glucose 6-phosphate the
top chromatogram the top pane is
actually what's called a total ion
chromatogram so this shows you all three
compounds in the same pain below it I've
separated out the three separate sugars
but you can see that they are separated
here it's not total baseline separation
but you can easily identify the
different sugars fri two sugars using
this this methodology and these are all
isobaric as well and the other problem
you have with these these three material
three compounds is that they have very
similar fragmentation patterns and
you'll see for the fructose one
phosphate the major when the major
fragments ions is actually also present
in the glucose 6-phosphate so you really
ideally need to separate this out
chromatographic Li are they using CEO
other techniques to properly identify
these phosphorylated sugars and these
and these the presence and the
identification of these was was
confirmed by the cost standard edition
of the individual phosphor itís sugars
which were purchased from sigma-aldrich
again looking at the linearity for these
three phosphorylated monosaccharides
they're all again as with a disaccharide
they were linear C get a squared values
of point nine nine point nine nine eight
for example shown in this slide again
for all this work I have not used any
infamous tanners whatsoever because or
based on standards with it without any
internal standards and this data was
processed using multicom which is a
software which comes with the a psychic
smash but
others of course we need to apply this
to real extracts so actually the
customer supply me with a wheat extract
the weeds extract however was was was
developed for hillock chromatography so
it actually contains a lot of methanol
in this sort of analysis you really want
to run these are more a quiz extracts so
the prep wasn't designed for for cen
arse is designed for hillock analysis so
I actually diluted the the real plans
exercised by of by a factor of eight and
then analyzed it and compared it with a
standard and I could actually identify
to phosphorylated sugars in the plant
extra and separately and separate the
glucose 1-phosphate the fructose woman
phosphate and you can see the wheat
extract compared with the standard where
you can see also if you look closely is
the migration times that are very very
similar and comparing a standard suis
extra and virtually the same this aids
in the discrimination of these two
compounds that's looking at
phosphorylated sugars of course we have
the citric acid cycle which is also
important in in polar metabolomics and
here is an example separating to the
compounds which were part of the citric
acid cycle and this is situated
isocitrate in this example if you look
at the the bottom two panes of this this
picture you can see sit to a turn
isocitrate again I geometrical isomers
in this case the position of the hydroxy
group moves across the molecule and that
causes a different isoelectric point of
a pKa of the compounds and you can
separate these quite well by CSI ms and
you get baseline resolution of these two
important metabolites in the citric acid
cycle okay and that's shown the top pane
of the electro three tech separation of
these two compounds again using the same
method as I applied through the
phosphorylated sugars previously again I
then start to look at other
compounds these include ascorbate and
pyruvate again he's involved in he sort
of energy cycles of plants and animal
and metabolomics and also I looked at
again standard curves for these
materials for these compounds and again
you can see for isocitrate and situate
it's linear and also with a score beam
and pyruvate all the calibration client
lines I'd saw were linear for a series
of standards which would run for these
tests metabolites in this case I try to
base around what's what were the
physiological levels and suggested by
the customer again one of the questions
that is always asked of me is that how
reproducible is cee and here you see
three separating injections of a
standard comparing glucose 1-phosphate
sucrose six phosphate and isocitrate
what can see from the three separate
injections is actually these might the
migration times you see from these three
different metabolites are virtually
identical between injections so the
actual cv of migration time is really
low so you're getting very reproducible
at o'farrell grams when you when I
repeated this analysis on the same
standard and actually the calibration
lines I've shown you during this
presentation are from the multiple
injection of the same standard and
different standards so these are not
just simple one point calibration lines
there for multiple injections of the
standards again the the other question
which is often asked is how reproducible
intra and inter a day so this is can he
get this esi-ms and this data was
acquired in this area by a collaboration
we have with leiden university and rouse
the dr ali r amateur who's the when the
lease scientists there actually has a
CSI instruments and he actually
replicated this data in his institute I
you ran a series of tests to
study the inter and intra day statistics
for the repeat analysis of samples
metabolomic samples on the system and
here you can see the cv's you achieved
the in today CBS are all less than
twelve percent again we're not using
internal standards these are simply
based on repeat analysis without any
internal standard markers and again the
in today migration time CBS are all
about a percents they're really low so
this shows you some of the some of the
repeatability and reproducibility you
can get by using CSI ms and this is data
which has been provided kindly by the
group at Leiden University and it's due
to and is due to be submitted for
publication soon so I just want to go
back to some of the questions which were
originally posed by the researcher who
wanted to see where the CSI ms can be
used in the area of metabolomic
specifically around Pola metabolomics so
the first question in the artists can
you analyze basically cationic
metabolites for example and derivatives
amino acids as well as a light
metabolize using the same capillary and
from this data you can see yes you can
because basically all i've done here is
use the same capillary the same
background electrolyte conditions and to
simply change the voltage in the methods
to do exactly this so I've proved that
you can do that without having to change
hplc columns and mobile phases which is
something you would have to do if we try
to do this by other approaches for
example lcms the next question which was
posed the beginning of this presentation
was can you detect metabolites of
physiological relevant levels and again
yes if you look at the example of the
wheat extract this is just one example
from a series of tests I did you can see
that yes we can eat with me text for
example mono phosphorylated sugars in
wheat extracts even was diluted sample
eight fold which was provided by the by
research in Germany and you can see that
the linear calibration lines were
achieve their every component testers
are all linear and they're not quadratic
so yes it is reproducible is linear and
yes we can detect these physiologically
relevant relevant levels can you
separate isobaric metabolites which are
just geometrical isomers for example the
phosphorylated sugars and yes I've shown
you can do that you cannot not only
separate phosphorylate these sugars but
also organic gases like I citric
isocitrate can be separated and in case
of citric acids its rate and even the
phosphorylated disaccharides baseline
resolve separated and by using CS IMF
and finally can do this with low sample
consumption well if you do the math the
actual sample consumption eat with both
injections it will be the order of less
than 50 nanometers so you can run your
sample in positive cationic metabolomics
and negative català metabolomics by CSI
ms and use the order of 15 unelected
severe sample which is then allow you to
move your samples other techniques and
repeat the analysis there's no other
technique was used such a little volume
of sample and allows you the ability to
use to analyze your sample with several
different approaches now so this is just
the start of us of developed in this
area at science I think this is a
research project i started about about
eight to nine months ago and i'm
planning to move to continue this area
and some of the things we're going to
try is to look at optimizing the sample
preparation for the CSI ms ideally what
we would do was was not actually prepare
our samples as for hillock comments or
we will prepare them for CSI ms so we
wouldn't delete them into methanol we
keep them in in aqueous conditions and
then we're also looking in negative mode
to think about modifying the sample
conditions to see if we can do some ice
attacker for research type injections
where we can load more onto the
capillary and then
a better sensitivity in the method of
course we have planned to expand this to
other metabolomics areas and this
initial study was just around the sort
of very polar metabolites which will
import and implant metabolomics but
we're against these sort of metabolites
is important are there is as well
including a mouse assays like mouse
central sponsored cerebral spinal fluid
testing and we think about applying this
to the detectives small chain fatty
acids and also look at human yielding
from metabolomic as well so there are
several areas now we can start applying
this technique to tackling finally I
like to like to like to acknowledge some
of the contributors to this presentation
again some of the slides I show you
today were provided by researchers using
CSI ms and the laboratories for the
ohmic slide on a first knowledge
professor Herbert lindner who's done a
lot of testing in the illness especially
around histone chemistry and histones in
in yeast cells and digest histones and
secondly and more importantly I want to
acknowledge rowie as well he has been my
sort of co-author and co-worker in this
area and he's actually repeated all this
study in his lab in Leiden to confirm
the method is transferable he got as a
clear same results as me and you can see
that some of the reproducibility and
repeatability testing was actually done
in raleys lab enlighten so a big thank
you to rally for the the data he
supplied is flied me here so that ends
the presentation for the day for myself
in the area of metabolomics and now I'm
open for questions so please if you have
any questions please send them through
to me and I'm happy to ask them now
thank you dr. Locke for that informative
presentation before we get to our
questions I want to remind our audience
how to submit them you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window and will sure
try to get to as many of your questions
as we can
our first question in the separation of
the phosphorylated sugars how much of
each analyzer is injected into the
capillary um it's as well I suppose
you're looking at the injection of low
microgram per meal so because they're
low mass the actual loading volume is
the order of 10 am-9 liters so your
Europe you're probably loading pika
moles of material onto the capillary so
the actual loading amount is very low
yeah if you compare with some of the
peptide work I've done in the past that
were actually loaded at the modes of
material on the capillary so the
sensitivity you get here is around the
low flows of running CSI ms that allows
you to load low amounts on columnist
still detect the material wait thank you
for that answer we do have another
question do you have to apply any
pressure to maintain your electrical
contact in nigg I on ms mode with
reverse polarity depends on the
capillary in this case because you're
running it would be a few silicate in
reverse polarity you have to apply some
pressure because there's a slight what's
called a letter osmotic flow which is
running away from the mass spec in the
method I used to I typically applied a
couple of psi pressure and with some of
the other capillaries and some of the
other modes no you aren't apply any
pressure the electrical optic flow
itself is enough to generate the flow
you need to detect your lines great
thank you our next question can I inject
larger volumes of extracts in order to
increase the lod I think we haven't
tried it yet we for loading larger
volumes and extracts what we would do is
we try to use a personalized attack of
rhesus in which case what you do is you
actually delete your sample into a salty
solution which allows backing that
allows you to inject more and fillmore
of your capillary
with sample to increase the sensitivity
the other approach which has been using
by several groups is to use electro
kinetic injection in this case what you
do is to physically apply a voltage to
your sample that drives all your analyte
into the capillary and then you apply a
separation voltage if you do this
approach you can basically suck yourself
or dry of sample of analytes and then
really increase your sensitivity of your
now Isis however because you're
depleting your sample you have to
therefore in a future injection run it
from a separate well you can't go back
to the same wall and analyze the same
sample with electro kinetic analysis so
yes there are ways to increase your
sensitivity a little more on great our
next question can this be applied in
triple TOS 6,600 system yes it can we've
I've actually used this this method on
cue trap systems on triple quad systems
on q tal systems including 6600 so yes
you can apply it on several different
types of mass spectrometers great thank
you for that we have another question
the loading volume of cee is low how
does this affect the sensitivity of this
technique compared to LC ms ah good
question i think really it's all about a
combination of iron generation as well
as loading if you look at high flow yet
you're running there a couple hundred
microliters per minute you're lyin
generation is relatively poor because
you have to get rid of all the solvent
but you can inject ten microliters with
CSI ms basically you're now running at
13 analytics per minute or less of some
sinister TSA's here your iron generation
is really high but you're actually
injecting a lot less in reality the work
item the testing i recently done and CSI
ms is can be equivalent to about a a
five microliters injection by high flow
lc-ms so the lovo
vol injection onto the capillary is
countered dramatically by the high
efficiency of iron generation you get to
these low flows great Thank You our next
question how easy is it to connect the
CES I to a mass spectrometer um it's
very easy basically all you need to do
all you need to have is an eye spray
sauce and adapter which allows you to
connect in the opportunity capillary I
actually now use a CSI instrument as
another infusion device over connecting
the syringe because all you simply do is
plug in the op TMS adapter into the
holder on to nano spray device and apply
pressure and you're running it's really
very simple I can do it in about five or
ten minutes typically great thank you
our next question can you connect cesi
two different types of mass
spectrometers yes you can and as I
mentioned I've run CSI ms on triple
sophs systems including the 5600 you can
also connect to 6640 604 may be signs
but I've also connected as well to Q
trap systems and you can also connected
to also triple quadrupole systems as
well basically any system which which
will fit the Nano spray sauce which can
hold the adapter for the cartridge you
can then connect it to to mass spec I
see great our next question are you
planning to expand the esi-ms two
different metabolomic studies yes we are
this is probably the first area we've
applied to because there's a lot of
questions around this area and we shall
have had from researchers but yeah we're
we're planning to apply this to other
heirs of parliament tablets we have a
list of some like a couple of hundred
metabolites with plans to try by CSI MSO
I think this is just a start to be
perfectly honest in this area great
thank you we have our next question how
repeatable is the separation of the mono
phosphorylated sugars again very good
question again I repeated this myself in
the lab on on two or three different
Kapil arrays but I was again I wanted to
EE check this so what I did was actually
transfer the method to I said go worker
raui he's based in lighting who's worked
with me and untested the method and he
actually then set it up in his system
and he repeated the separation so I've
confirmed that you can't actually
physically transfer the method to
another Institute in another country on
a complete new system and it's fully
reproducible great thank you I think
that's all the time we have for
questions as at the beginning of the
presentation our audience will now see
another poll question appearing on the
screen that asks would you be interested
in incorporating see esi-ms technology
in your look toward laboratory workflow
and if so what time frame if you could
please take a moment to answer that
question will be sure to follow up with
you to answer any other questions you
might have about the CES I and that
technology and before we close I'd also
like to thank dr. Locke for his time
today dr. Locke do you have any final
comments for our audience no thank you
brenda i think for me i've been running
lcms instruments for I would say 20
years and I I was really surprised how
easy it is to connect the systems
together I would just get anyone to
start looking the papers because it's
really easy technology to use I think
people i think you'll see a big increase
in this technology moving forward thank
you for that dr. Locke I'd also like to
thank of course our sponsors IX for
making today's webcast possible and this
webinar will be available for on-demand
viewing through March of 2016 you'll be
receiving an email from lab roots
alerting you when just webcast is
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who might have missed today's
live of
thank you again for joining us today see
you next time goodbye